[Music]
some politicians have been saying
americans should not be allowed to vote
unless they can pass the same
naturalization test that immigrants need
to pass in order to become citizens and
it's controversial yeah a lot of people
are upset about that i have said this
before i think it's a great idea okay i
think all americans if you're going to
vote you should know something about the
country right to prove my point once
again i'm going to be the only late
night talk show host to take the u.s
citizenship test on the air with some
help from my pal andy all right
we're all dreaming here
these are the questions oh yeah man i'm
gonna i'm gonna i've been studying up
for this i think i'm ready to go all
right here we go okay here we go
question number one yeah
how long is a president's term four
years
who wrote the declaration of
independence thomas jefferson
name three things our government is
designed to protect at all costs our
freedom our rights and our secret blend
of 11 herbs and spices
how long is the waiting period to buy a
gun in texas okay you have to wait nine
months until you're out of the womb
is america's greatest contribution to
science the chip isle at walmart
what's the most polluted river in the
united states joan
[Music]
[Applause]
according to our justice system a man is
innocent until he's proven to be a
member of the nfl right
a new poll has miley cyrus swinging
around it okay there you go
why hasn't an american visited the moon
since 1972 because of neil armstrong's
yelp review
if you're an american who likes
headphones your motto is bows before
hoes
[Applause]
does the government have the right to
track our internet activity i hope not
but if they do i should make it clear
that i was doing research for a book on
milfs
what original trilogy character are you
hoping they bring back for star wars
episode seven the screenwriter
[Applause]
all right list all 12 months of the year
as if they were in an ad for subway
sandwiches see that's january breduwary
munch taste brawl mayo june witch
july
og taste
september septober september
september okay this one's tricky okay
i'm gonna name a famous american and you
have to tell me their favorite euphemism
for going number two
blake griffin a slam dunk plus the foul
peyton manning hitting the wide open
tight end
taylor swift breaking up with a tiny
boyfriend
what was the significance of marbury
versus madison margaret vs madison was a
landmark united states supreme court
case from 1803 in which the court
according to a majority opinion written
by chief justice john marshall formed
the basis for the exercise of judicial
review in the united states under
article 3 of the constitution thereby
defined the boundary between the
constitutionally separate executive and
judicial branches of the american
government since the constitution lacked
a clear statement authorizing the
federal courts to nullify the acts of
co-equal branches
and
finally
kanye west's euphemism for number two
dropping my next
[Applause]
single congratulations